police continue their efforts to
identify the body of a boy discovered
behind some bushes friday morning
hikers found the boy's body off a trail
in the town of mountain springs just off
highway 160
between las vegas and perhaps victoria
saha joins us from the newsroom victoria
spoke to the detective on the case
and we understand they desperately need
the community to help
yes their focus is on nye and clark
county they do believe
someone knows who this boy is they have
crossed off any indication that this may
be a missing boy from
other states police thought they had a
solid lead when a mother claimed the
sketch of the boy was of her son but it
turned out to be a case of
misidentification
a digitally enhanced picture was
provided by the national center for
missing
missing and exploited children and
police say they have received hundreds
of tips
they are encouraging teachers to take a
close look at the picture
to see if it could have been a student
however they welcome tips from anyone no
matter how big
or small they may be he's
4 11 123 pounds
you know if you recognize this little
boy
and now you don't see him call the tip
line
we're going to go check his welfare and
we're doing that on every tip
and you know we're so far hundreds of
doors we have knocked on
here again is a picture of the boy he
does have black hair and brown eyes and
believed to be hispanic
the boy is a victim of a homicide
however police are not releasing
information right now on how he died
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now